mientras el reloj marcaba las 8 de la
noche señalando el inicio del toque de
queda en chino y wisconsin cientos de
personas permanecieron en las calles
para expresar su ira por el tiroteo de
la policía contra jake blake el
gobernador demócrata del estado se
apresuró a condenar la violencia en un
tuit feroz dijo que la víctima no era el
primer hombre afroamericano que ha
recibido un disparo o ha sido herido o
asesinado sin piedad por individuos de
las fuerzas del orden y ha pedido que se
hagan cambios con más urgencia debemos
comenzar el largo pero importante camino
para asegurar que nuestro estado y
nuestro país empiezan a cumplir con
nuestras promesas de equidad y justicia
la policía dice que estaba reaccionando
a lo que llamó un incidente doméstico el
domingo checo blake de 29 años fue visto
incumpliendo órdenes de la policía
cuando quiso entrar en su coche abrieron
fuego varias veces el hombre permanece
en condición crítica
la pareja de blake dijo que sus hijos
estaban sentados en la parte de atrás
del coche mirando mientras su padre
recibía los disparos
eran dos oficiales varones y una mujer y
los dos oficiales masculinos lo
detuvieron al instante como ya sabes
levanten sus manos ese hombre
literalmente lo agarró por la camisa y
miró hacia el otro lado y le disparó con
los niños en la parte de atrás gritando
gritando mientras intentaba luchar
contra esta mujer policía para que me
deje sacar a los niños del coche ella me
dijo que no
el incidente provocó disturbios el
domingo por la noche y 24 horas después
en wisconsin y varios estados sacudidos
por el movimiento black lives madre los
manifestantes se preparan para nuevos
enfrentamientos callejeros